welcome to this video playing a blitz
came here on the ICC 5 million chance
against grandmas a mandragora now he's
telling me ha yeah it's a very very old
friend of mine Grandmaster schibler
originally from Germany of course the
team went to live in Thailand to
Thailand Thailand so on what what I
didn't really look at the board what is
this a headshot hmmm I wonder this is
one of those cases where not an early 95
might be possible and there's a five
okay I don't want to go right into 95
with the temple so I go to be eight yeah
I don't know if this was the most
precise way to to enter the Hedgehog but
chill at least 95 now does not hit the
Queen this is really a standard type of
sacrifice now I don't think it's
possible right now well maybe it is I
mean but I'm not forced to take it oh
wow that's a very direct approach but
interesting because the early night d7
here does not offer the slight square
for the night i guess i'll play h6 now
we probably play a form okay well that's
interesting way to play I wonder should
i do something really crazy here like g5
this leads to a completely wacky
position takes takes Bishop takes rook
g8 I'll play I'll play this back he move
takes takes Bishop takes rook g8 is the
idea very very risky obviously but
interesting they just asked me a face on
video yes laughs yes it is I came
instead of rook GA there also was
possibly d5 with the screen h2 idea but
it's not more than just to check at the
moment and with this I actually like if
he takes Knight takes its it's not easy
for him to cover g4 with a decent move
and the taking I mean if you really want
to give up the dark squared Bishop here
hmm with g44 plate not sure yet this I
didn't really look at and this is a
mistake of course I mean a mistake not
to look at it
cause is just just a good move probably
hmm okay should I go eat five I cannot
really play anything and he's also moves
yeah let's blast this open of course the
King only eight posing the rook it's a
tricky yeah the question is what now
night f5 disposal sadly I'll take a form
okay this one you know if i take he will
take with the pawn of course okay
I'll take here there's no way to make
this work I guess no okay night h7 how
crazy is in smooth probably very crazy d
for hangs if i take here ed well that's
no good way no good way
okay I'll do that it's completely crazy
by the way he wrote to me okay you got
you are the one to going to explain that
yeah that's true I'm completely
responsible for my own nonsense that are
sometimes play on video okay do all the
ideas that now I'm attacking the night
here that will take g5 possibly maybe he
can just play Knight f3 maybe that's
really a intently crazy position it's
probably excellent for Wyatt I mean I
have a bad feeling but the thing is it's
it's also completely irrational so
anything anything can happen okay
although now f6 is the the toughest muth
was just intense to take g4 and I try
that maybe maybe I can just do that but
okay they might know I can take edge
form and I can't take g4 really now I'm
on two minutes and he's on one something
after 17 moose this will get really
crazy I mean it is crazy already but
with the time kind of take here can I
take it I'll just take it
yeah now can probably hear you it's
covering the rook it's 95 maybe Wow
I can take hear you or is that some some
check I don't know let's let's take it
check ok and now maybe first take here
yeah if you give this check i have an ID
f7 or bishop f7 Wow
your chest probably good for black now
but what the position I have chance is
checking it's still not entirely easy
maybe maybe here and then King g6 time
morning yeah now 95 is a big big threat
still 95 Queen Queen Hanks I guess no
time no time at all white resign yeah
what a crazy game no idea yeah it's
sometimes sometimes happens in the in
the Hedgehog but if whiter goes in for
full swing attacking mode that it gets
really crazy yeah g5 is probably not not
really great but it leads to to an
invite for yeah the computer assess it
is that much much better fall forward
yeah this has expect a suspected but
still it's tricky yeah here the computer
wants single night f5 which was for the
main move I expected but no idea what's
going on here probably a white is better
with 93 95 mmm I don't know which
obviously really crazy white also has
got his King exposed hmm i don't really
know i mean if i take this is probably
falling only 60 cannot do that
Chuck difficult computer wants to play
Quincy said maybe this make sense get to
get this into the game and maybe Castle
long it's it's probably correct what the
computer is giving white almost winning
but of course it's really crazy you know
maybe here there was something better
computer wants to play Bishop h4 ed for
g5 which is completely unhuman way to
play Queen yeah it looks it looks very
dangerous admittedly this possibility
you're just taking now computer gives
white a slight advantage funny enough
and here yeah this is also good for word
but obviously super difficult to play 94
yeah white is still retaining a big edge
according to the comp and here I just
blended 2nite xf6 wow you can just take
a 6 ok and now I'm winning instead of
plus 9 for what it sets it went down to
two a loss check yeah I'm sure there's
nothing nothing to have to find anymore
i guess it didn't i didn't allow any any
crazy stuff yeah and turn and white lost
the Queen yeah completely completely
wacky game and of course this is I think
up to here I mean it was crazy and and
everything but maybe it was playable in
the practical game but like did
buttercream 95 is just check is just
losing the house but he was probably so
irritated to fight the whole procedure
the TM he didn't he didn't play
alright thanks for watching